Each one of the rooms the characters encounter
in Escape Room has an intended solution.
But if Breath of the Wild has taught me anything,
it’s that there are often more than one
possible solution for any given puzzle, and
I don’t think they always found the intended
path.
Stick around to the end of the video if you
want to hear the real solutions for these
rooms.
[INTRO]
Welcome back to Things You Missed and Happy
New Year 2019.
I’ve got an exciting week packed with content
for you this week and to kick it all off,
we’re going to be covering some of the hidden
details and their meanings in the first horror
movie of the year: Escape Room.
Let’s start with the beginning of the movie.
The opening shot pulls out from a chess board.
You’re probably thinking that this is a
microcosm of the entire movie being a chess
match against the creators of the game, and
the participants are just trying to become
the last piece standing.
There’s actually a little bit more to it
than that.
When Zoey heads back to her dorm after class,
there’s a poster advertising a chess group
meeting at the college.
That might be where she gets some of her deductive
reasoning skills, because I spotted a chess
piece in her room.
But it wasn’t just any chess piece, it was
a King, and if you’ve ever played Chess
you know that the King is the one piece that
must remain standing in order for the game
to continue.
So when Zoey faked her death in the hospital
themed room, I knew he hadn’t heard the
last of her.
But that’s not the only clue left in the
opening scene, the flash-forward of Ben’s
final test.
There is also some Latin text printed on the
top of the wall near the ceiling that says
Acta Est Fabula, which roughly translates
to “The Play Is Over” or “The Performance
Is Over”, a clue that the entire game was
created for entertainment, which is explained
once Ben reaches the final room.
That’s not the only clue towards the game
being an entertainment trail for the super-rich.
We are first introduced to Zoey at her college
physics lecture.
Her professor brings up the phrase “A watched
pot never boils”, and explains how that
may actually be true under the Quantum Zeno
effect in which observation stops movement
in atoms.
Zoey’s plan for getting out kind of mirrors
that effect, she smashes every camera in the
room so she’s no longer being observed,
then passes out and waits for the cleanup
crew to come around so she can take them out
and escape.
After that lecture she has a little chat with
her professor, who tells her that reducing
variables won’t change the outcome.
At the time it’s more of a reference to
her life choices of being an introvert, but
you could also apply it to the game and say
she’s doomed to eventually lose no matter
what.
The name of the company who runs the Escape
Room is Minos.
The logo of this company is explained in the
movie, but the name is not.
It goes back to ancient Greek mythology.
Minos of the first King of Crete who commanded
that seven young boys and seven young girls
be sent into the Labyrinth, a giant maze structure
that houses a minotaur, with the intention
that they be eaten by the Minotaur.
In other words, the company being named Minos
should have been a huge red flag that the
seven contestants were not meant to survive.
Seven seems to be a recurring number throughout
the movie as well.
In addition to the seven contestants when
you add in the guy introduced into the game
at the winners room, there are 7 rooms and
the clue in the second room is a 7 letter
word.
Seven, of course is considered a lucky number,
and the winner of each game is considered
lucky to be alive.
When Zoey and Ben meet up again after getting
out alive, they get lunch together on St.
Patrick’s day, which is often considered
to be a lucky day.
But let’s go back to when the contestants
all meet.
Amanda, the redhead girl, reads a newspaper
headline about 5 people being found burned
alive.
I would theorize this is from another iteration
of the game, or a beta testing of the game.
The waiting room turns out to be the first
trial room, the giant oven.
Anyone who’s played Ocarina of Time should
have figured out how those weight sensitive
pedestals work, but it didn’t click for
them until it was almost too late.
The obvious intended solution was to fill
up the cups with water and place them on the
switches, however, they didn’t have enough
water because Amanda drank some of it, so
they ended up using some liquid that Ben had
in a flask.
They also could have had someone pee in the
last cup, or place literally any heavy object
in the room on top of the cup, but they were
lucky enough to have the flask on hand.
So they moved onto the inside of the cabin,
where they needed a 7-letter word to advance.
If you don’t remember the word was “Rudolf”.
There were three clues in in the cabin and
Ben was able to figure it out having only
found two, the text that said YOU’LL GO
DOWN IN HISTORY, which to be honest should
have been enough on its own.
The other clue they saw was the reindeer mantles.
Again, probably should have been enough on
their own.
But they didn’t seem to notice that the
camera in this room is the only one in the
game with a blinking red recording light,
which could have also tipped them off as a
clue pointing to Rudolph’s shining red nose.
After solving that puzzle, they move onto
the ice level.
It start with them finding the jacket, Zoey
gets to wear it for a bit, and she discovers
the compass with the text, True North is a
lie.
This is actually the same compass seen hanging
from her mother’s pocket when she later
has the flashback to the plane crash that
killed her family AND the brand of the compass
is Stanley, London and London happens to be
the location she buys the plane tickets to
in order to try to infiltrate Minos at the
end of the movie.
Meanwhile, Mike gets distracted by the Husky
dog, which matches the description of his
old dog that he told everyone about when they
are all in the waiting room.
This leads him to find the fishing rod in
the tree.
The compass leads to the magnet and the magnet
goes on the bottom of the fishing rod to help
them find the ice box with the key.
This is where the intended solution is a little
bit unclear, and I don’t really buy that
they are supposed to use the warmth of their
hands to melt the ice.
I do have a theory though.
There’s one object that is never used, the
thermometer.
Maybe they are supposed to break open the
thermometer and spill out the mercury on the
ice block.
I looked it up, and I guess Mercury is not
flammable, but in the presence of water it
can become explosive.
This is assuming that they don’t lose the
lighter, which they do when Danny falls through
the ice.
If you’re an expert on chemistry, let me
know if that would actually work, because
honestly I have no idea.
They also could have potentially started a
fire using branches from tree, so there may
have been more than one solution there.
Next room is the upside down 8-Ball Room,
where the song ‘Downtown’ plays over and
over on repeat.
Everything they need to know to solve this
puzzle is in the lyrics if they had only stopped
to listen.
“Just listen to the music of the the traffic
in the city.”
It’s literally telling them, stop and listen
to the music first.
“Linger on the sidewalk where the neon signs
are pretty.
How can you lose.”
In this case, the “sidewalk” is the area
on the sides of the room, where the floor
isn’t falling away and the “neon signs”
are the color coded puzzle which corresponds
to the numbers on the balls of the pool table.
It’s telling them if they study these signs,
they won’t lose.
“Downtown, things will be great when you’re
downtown.”
This line is a bit trickier, but basically
it’s telling them to go down, but since
the room is upside-down they really need to
go up, and that’s where Amanda finds the
safe.
“When you’ve got worries all the noise
and the hurry seems to help I know.
Downtown.”
This just lets them know they have limited
time to solve this room.
“Don’t hang around and let your problems
surround you there are movie shows.
Downtown.”
Amanda ends up hanging from the telephone
wire, and the problems that surround her are
the bottomless pits on each side of her.
I mean, not bottomless, but you know what
I mean.
She sits there and “hangs around” and
ends up paying the price for it.
“You may find somebody kind to help and
understand you.
Someone who is just like you and needs a gentle
hand to guide them along.”
The other contestants literally offer Amanda
a helping hand when she’s hanging there,
but she doesn’t take it.
This movie is absolutely filled with other
possible clues, so if you caught anything
I didn’t notice in my video -- go ahead
and let me know in the comments.
New year.
New merch.
That’s right, now you can get a My Life
Is A Horror Movie merch, which looks like
this, exclusively from the CZsWorld merch
store.
Look how good this looks.
I’m gonna get it.
And you should get it too.
The link will be waiting for you in the description.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.